[Music]
the next screw that falls out is going
to be you
hey
what was that
eat
my
shorts
oh high school a time in our lives
filled with friends bullies love
heartbreak and all the hormones in
between
i mean for many these were the defining
years of our lives so it comes to no
surprise that these movies became
defining works of a generation
captain my captain
sit down mr anderson
[Music]
you hear me
sit
down sit down
we previously made a list for the top 10
high school movies and all those were
ranked by tomato meter from the critics
but for this list we are focusing on the
audience score we wanted to highlight
the fan favorite high school movies that
have won our hearts capture the team's
school spirit and remain quotable even
to this day bueller
bueller
bueller
bueller
while some of the more popular high
school movies will appear here we'll see
some that didn't make the previous list
we've done but don't worry you didn't
have to study because we got you covered
you just might want to take notes as we
count down our list of fan favorite high
school movies
[Music]
number 10 the perks of being a
wallflower
socially awkward teen charlie is a
wallflower always watching life from the
sidelines until two charismatic students
become his mentors free-spirited sam and
her step-brother patrick helped charlie
discover the joys of friendship first
love music and more while a teacher
sparks charlie's dreams of becoming a
writer however as his new friends
prepare to leave for college charlie's
inner sadness threatens to shatter his
newfound confidence starring logan
lerman emma watson ezra miller and
directed by steven chuboski critics say
the perks of being a wallflower is a
heartfelt and sincere adaptation that's
bolstered by strong lead performances
hey everyone
everybody
everyone
your glasses to charlie
what did i do you didn't do anything
we just want to toast our new friend
you see things
and you understand
you're a wallflower
what is it what's wrong
i didn't think anyone noticed me
well we didn't think there was anyone
cool left to meet
so come on everyone
to charlie to charlie
welcomes the islands of misfit toys
number nine the last picture show
high school seniors and best friends
sunny and dwayne live in a dying texas
town the handsome duane is dating local
beauty jaycee while sunny is having an
affair with the coach's wife ruth as
graduation nears both boys contemplate
their futures while dwayne eyes the army
and sonny takes over a local business
each boy struggles to figure out if he
can escape the dead in town and build a
better life somewhere else starring
timothy bottoms jeff bridges cybel
shepherd and directed by peter
bogdanovic critics say making excellent
use of its period and setting peter
bogdanovich's small town coming of age
story is a sad but moving classic filled
with impressive performances
i wonder what my chances are this
morning of interesting new kids and john
keats no at all
yo bob
well i read that poem his about the
nightingale and i didn't think it's so
good
sounded like he wanted to be a
nightingale right i i don't think he
wanted to be a nightingale joe bob
maybe he just wanted to be immortal all
you have to do to be immortal is lead a
good christian life
anyone can do it if they love the lord
well maybe so joe bob maybe so
here now let me let me read you this
when old age shall this generation waste
thou shalt remain
in midst of other woe than ours
a friend to man
to whom thou sayst
beauty is truth
truth beauty
that is all ye know on earth
and all ye need to
number eight dazed and confused
this coming-of-age film follows the
mayhem of a group of rowdy teenagers in
austin texas celebrating the last day of
high school in 1976. the graduating
class heads for a popular pool hall and
joins an impromptu keg party however
star football player randall pink floyd
has promised to focus on the
championship game and abstain from
partying meanwhile the incoming freshmen
try to avoid being hazed by the seniors
most notably the sadistic bully fred
obanion starring jason london wiley
wiggins mila jovovich sasha jensen and
directed by richard linklater critics
say featuring an excellent ensemble cast
a precise feel for the 1970s and a
killer soundtrack days and confused is a
funny affectionate and clear-eyed look
in high school life
not to indulge in any alcohol drug sex
after 12 or any other illegal activity
not my shadow
later baby found that in the glove
compartment man you know you're the
third person who's giving me this today
god
but what do you reckon you're gonna do
i don't know man i'll probably end up
signing i just don't want to give in so
easy man it's the same [ __ ] they
tried to pull in my day you know if it
ain't that piece of paper some other
choice they're gonna try and make for
you
you gotta do what randall pink floyd
wants to do man
let me tell you this the older you do
get the more rules you're gonna try to
get you to follow
you just gotta keep living man
l-i-v-i-n
man if you're gonna sign that paper man
you should throw a little grass right in
the middle man roll it up
[Music]
number seven rushmore
when a beautiful first grade teacher
arrives at a prep school she soon
attracts the attention of an ambitious
teenager named max who quickly falls in
love with her max turns to the father of
two of his schoolmates for advice on how
to woo the teacher however the situation
soon gets complicated when max's new
friend becomes involved with her setting
the two pals against one another in a
war for her attention starring jason
schwartzman bill murray olivia williams
and directed by wes anderson critics say
this cult favorite is a quirky
coming-of-age story with fine off-kilter
performances from jason schwartzman and
bill murray
max you're 15 years old
attraction doesn't enter into it
if you say so
look all i'm getting at is that
i've never met anyone like you
so you can take that for whatever it's
worth
i think i can safely say i've never met
anyone like you either
you haven't have you
want to shake hands
i'm glad we had this conversation
so am i
number six hoop dreams
every school day african-american
teenagers william gates and arthur agui
travel 90 minutes each way from inner
city chicago to saint joseph high school
in westchester illinois a predominantly
white suburban school well known for the
excellence of its basketball program
gates and a gay dream of nba stardom and
with the support of their close-knit
families they battle the social and
physical obstacles that stand in their
way starring william gates arthur gee
and steve james who also directed the
film critics say one of the most
critically acclaimed documentaries of
all time hoop dreams is a rich complex
heartbreaking and ultimately deeply
rewarding film that uses high school
hoops as a jumping off point to explore
issues of race class and education in
modern america
[Music]
you know four years ago
that's all i used to dream about was
playing an nba
i don't really dream about it like that
anymore
you know even though
i love playing basketball
but you know i want to do other things
with my life too
i love you
[Applause]
if i have to stop playing basketball
right now i think i'll still be happy
i think i would
[Music]
that's why when somebody say and you
know when you get to the nba don't
forget about me and all that stuff i
should say then well if i don't make it
but you don't forget about me
number five dead poets society
a new english teacher john keating is
introduced to an all-boys preparatory
school that is known for its ancient
traditions and high standards he uses
unorthodox methods to reach out to his
students who face enormous pressures
from their parents and the school with
keating's help students neil perry todd
anderson and others learn to break out
of their shells pursue their dreams and
seize the day starring robin williams
robert shawn leonard ethan hawk and
directed by peter weir critics say
affecting performances from the young
cast and a genuinely inspirational turn
from robin williams grant peter weir's
prep school drama top honors
we don't read and write poetry because
it's cute
we read and write poetry because we are
members of the human race and the human
race
is filled with passion
medicine law business engineering these
are noble pursuits and necessary to
sustain life
but poetry beauty
romance love
these are what we stay alive for
the quote from whitman
oh me
o life of the questions of these
recurring
of the endless trains of the faithless
of cities filled with the foolish what
good amid these o me o life
answer
that you are here
that life exists
and identity
that the powerful play goes on and you
may contribute a verse
number four the breakfast club
five high school students from different
walks of life endure a saturday
detention under a power hungry principal
the disparate group includes rebel john
princess claire outcast allison branny
bryan and andrew the jock each has a
chance to tell his or her story making
the others see them a little differently
and when the day ends they question
whether school will ever be the same
starring emilio estevez molly ringwald
judd nelson anthony michael hall and
directed by john hughes critics say the
breakfast club is a warm insightful and
very funny look into the inner lives of
teenagers
what god's name is going on in here
what was that ruckus
uh what ruckus i was just in my office
and i heard a ruckus
could you describe the ruckus sir watch
your tongue young man watch it
what is this
what is that what what is that what is
that noise what noise
really sure there wasn't any noise
[Music]
that noise was that the noise you're
talking about no it wasn't that was not
the noise i was talking about
now i may not have caught you in the act
this time
but you can bet i will
you may book on that missy
and you
i will not be made a fool of
number three ferris bueller's day off
ferris bueller has an uncanny skill at
cutting classes and getting away with it
intending to make one last duck out
before graduation ferris calls in sick
borrows a ferrari and embarks on a
one-day journey through the streets of
chicago on ferris's trail is high school
principal rooney determined to catch him
in the act starring matthew broderick
alan ruck mia sarah and directed by john
hughes critics say matthew broderick
charms in ferris bueller's day off a
light and irrepressibly fun movie about
being young and having fun hi i'm
aprilman party of three for 12.
is there a problem you're abroad that's
right i'm abe froman the sausage king of
chicago
yeah
that's me
listen young man entrenu i'm very busy
here why don't you take the kids and go
back to the clubhouse
are you suggesting that i'm not who i
say i am i'm suggesting that you leave
before i have to get snooty snooty
snotty snotty okay abe
let's go i'm not going anywhere
no
we like to be seated listen young man
either you take the field trip outside
or i'm going to have to call
the police
the
you're going gonna call the police on me
yes
fine as a matter of fact i'll call them
myself
yes
called police
this'll be a hoot
number two back to the future in this
1980s sci-fi classic small town
california teen marty mcfly is thrown
back into the 50s when an experiment by
his eccentric scientist friend doc brown
goes awry traveling through time in a
modified delorean car marty encounters
young versions of his parents and must
make sure that they fall in love or
he'll cease to exist even more
dauntingly marty has to return to his
own time and save the life of doc brown
starring michael j fox christopher lloyd
leah thompson and directed by robert
zemeckis critics say inventive funny and
breathlessly constructed back to the
future is a rousing time travel
adventure with an unforgettable spirit
do you want to know your name i don't
want to know anything about you listen
i'm gonna read your thoughts
but see now you come here from a great
distance yeah exactly don't tell me
uh you want me to buy a subscription to
the saturday evening post no not a word
not a word not a word now quiet
uh
donations
you want me to make a donation
to the coast guard youth auxiliary
doc
i'm from the future
[Music]
i came here in a time machine that you
invented
now i need your help to get back to the
year 1985.
my god
do you know what this means
it means that this damn thing doesn't
work at all
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
super bad
high school seniors seth and evan have
high hopes for a graduation party now
the codependent teens plan to score
booze and babes so that they can become
part of the in crowd but separation
anxiety and two board police officers
complicate the pair's self-proclaimed
mission starring jonah hill michael
sarah christopher mintz class and
directed by greg mattola critics say
deftly balancing vulgarity and sincerity
while placing his protagonists in
excessive situations superbad is an
authentic take on friendship and the
overarching awkwardness of the high
school experience
okay your total is 96.59
are you okay mister
oh
i don't know man i think she looked
better before
but now that she can jog comfortably
she's in the best shape she's ever
what is this
what's that
without a cause
after moving to a new town troublemaking
teen jim stark is supposed to have a
clean slate although being the new kid
in town brings its own problems while
searching for some stability stark forms
a bond with a disturbed classmate plato
and falls for local girl judy however
judy is the girlfriend of neighborhood
tough buzz now when buzz violently
confronts jim and challenges him to a
drag race the new kids real trouble
begin starring james dean natalie wood
salmoneo and directed by nicholas ray
critics say rebel without a cause is a
searing melodrama featuring keen insight
into 50's juvenile attitude and james
dean's cool iconic performance
[Music]
thank
[Music]
ah
[Music]
juno
when precocious teen juno mcguff becomes
pregnant she chooses a failed rock star
and his wife to adopt her unborn child
complications occur when mark the
prospective father begins viewing juno
as more than just the mother of his
future child putting both his marriage
and the adoption in jeopardy starring
elliot page michael sarah jennifer
garner and directed by jason reitman
critics say one of the brightest
funniest comedies of the year juno's
smart script and direction are matched
by assured performances in a
coming-of-age story with a 21st century
twist
are you honestly and truly going to prom
with katrina devore
uh hi leah just just said that you were
gonna go with her yeah i did ask her if
she wanted to go
um a bunch of us from the team are gonna
go to bedding hannah and then go to the
prom and then go to vijay's parents
cabin
so
we're we're getting a stretched limo
your mom must be pretty stoked that
you're not taking me
you're mad why are you mad
i'm mad
i'm in a great mood i mean despite the
fact that well i'm in a fat suit that i
can't take off and despite the fact that
pretty much everyone's making fun of me
behind my back and despite the fact that
your little girlfriend gave me the stink
eye in art class yes trina is not my
girlfriend and i doubt that she gave you
the stink eye that's just
the way her face looks you know that's
just her face
and finally number one love and
basketball
monica and quincy are two childhood
friends who both aspire to be
professional basketball players quincy
whose father zeke plays for the los
angeles clippers is a natural talent and
a born leader monica is ferociously
competitive but sometimes becomes overly
emotional on the court over the years
the two begin to fall for each other but
their separate paths to basketball
stardom threatened to pull them apart
starring sana lathan omar epps alfree
woodard and directed by gina prince by
the wood critics say confident directing
and acting deliver an insightful look at
young athletics
so uh
who you going to the dance with anyway
spalding
no spoiler
see stupid
that's why you ain't getting recruited
who said i'm not getting recruited your
hot ass tampa that's who
i'm i'm not the one who put this scar
here where you're 11 years old cause he
was about to lose you know what
give me your best shot
give me your best shot i'm sick you
watch the damn line i'm watching the
road i'm tricking you hanging this over
my head now come on give me your best
shot don't tempt me
don't tempt me i'm warning you i'm
warning you
if you don't stall that bad attitude
no one's gonna recruit you please
you jump in some guy's face you you talk
smack and you get a pat on your ass
but because i'm a female i get told to
calm down and act like a lady
i'm a ball player
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content that you love
until next time i am your host naz perez
and we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you